rise and shine breakfast is ready in ten
minutes and don't make me come back up
there this is our town
it's a close-knit community a kind of
place where everyone knows everyone hi
mister hey how are you girls and we're
always there for each other
nice sermon pastor well you guys have on
for the rest today well don has a
basketball game yeah I've seen this guy
OOP it up around here this kid is so
rich
text your mom tomorrow when and where to
pick you up and don't do anything stupid
[Applause]
we're training for the Olympics sir
Sydney
he's been underwater for more than 15
minutes it's gonna be a recovery little
rescue you've done everything medically
possible there's nothing more what'd you
do please God said their spirit there's
a Muslim a fourteen-year-old st. Charles
boy who spent 15 minutes trapped under
water is continuing to fight for his
life
I don't believe John will survive the
night you don't know my son he is a
fighter so I need you to be the best for
John and you just let God do the rest
you are my pride and joy I can't wait to
see you because baskets and run up and
down again the Smith family he asked for
one thing please pray for John in the
water that day I was ready to give up
but then I hear this voice is telling me
go back there are nuts or God's talking
to you but I don't believe in God I
believe but maybe that only goes so far
something like this I'm your pastor I'm
supposed to walk alongside you for as
long as it takes
did you see the Facebook page go and by
roll call me I hope is gonna be okay
we're not gonna get through this alone
whatever you have for me Brian from time
you
you